so I want you to come back to this I'm
going to write it in a different way I'm
gonna write it in a different way do you
ever I said the constants they're
immaterial to this right I could name
them anything I like in fact I don't
really need any names here at all what
really matters is the numbers that are
attached does that make sense the
coefficients so let's write down just
the coefficients they're there the
important thing there right so I've got
a lot of three what's the coefficient of
B in the first equation it's a one okay
and you've got an eight when I write the
second equation I've got the same piece
of information all lined up in exactly
the same way what are the coefficients
negative two fine good okay now I want
to point out to you that with this
system of linear equations right these
four numbers are qualitatively different
to these two numbers not all these
numbers are created equal they have a
different role here how would you
describe how they're different how are
these four numbers is different to these
two think about it the magnitude is
smaller that's true but I could change
then I could make this and it would
still have the same thing that's
different about it to be harder to see
now that I've stripped away all of this
information but these numbers the values
are coincidental
but what's important is that these are
attached to the constants right their
coefficients and these guys are not
right they just knows that hater
so did distinguish between them I'm
going to slap a line between them which
is kind of equivalent to my equal sign
now here we go
he's my assistant of linear equations
but written without any of the algebra
stuff okay so to indicate that this is
all one collection of numbers I want to
put it together like this we call this
thing
a matrix now the plural of matrix is
matrices okay
just like the plural of vertex is
vertices you get the idea now I want you
to think about this um how can I go
about solving this using this instead of
using this okay when a little little
space what kinds of tools did we use to
manipulate these equations in this case
and how would they look when I bring
them over here okay so I'm going to use
this column in assemble this whole
system here right I'm gonna say it's
equal to another system that's
equivalent okay so I'm going to draw up
for myself
another little grid where I'm gonna pop
in all of my numbers okay I can say this
is gonna be equal to this in a very
similar way to for instance say that
this when in equation 3 come from when
it come from look carefully it's it's
equation 1 times 2 right so these
equations are the same said okay which
means that these two equations together
that system is equivalent to these two
together does that make sense
see that I haven't really changed
anything I'm gonna have the same
solutions if I use these as my starting
point verses this is my starting point
you'll still get the same answers at the
end you happy with that
okay so how would I do that here how
would I translate what happened over
here the tools you're familiar with the
process is you're familiar with here
will you take that first equation 3 1
hey and you multiply everything by 2
okay so I'll have the same coefficient 6
to 16 right
this equation hasn't changed down here
though it could if we want alright now
where do we go from here
what happened over here we were going to
add these two equations together okay by
the way how's it going through this yeah
this is a bit weird it's a bit awkward
you will think of things about this
process - sure like this is easier the
way I did it before but I want you to
have your mind team as to what things
are going to be better when we do it
this way they're not as I can already
think of one even having just written
one line once a draft he'll do next
he added them right so if I add these
two together I'll watch what happens
okay I'm going to adjust which line do
you want oh just the I'll just this line
okay so I'm going to add these two
together I'm going to add this one to
this one so that's going to become a
seven that's gonna become zero and then
this is going to become a it's for
anyone okay with that this equation
hasn't changed you happy with that
well what have I done what did I do
what'd I do I took the second line and I
added it to the first one
I took this row and I added to this one
right so 1 plus 6 is 7 negative 2 plus 2
is 0 and 5 plus 16 is 20 1 okay so far
yes so this line here this line here is
equivalent to this line all right
does that make sense I'm trying to mimic
what was done over here but in this new
form of notation right so this column
here these are all of the A's this
column here these are all of the B's and
these columns here these are all of the
numbers on their own
does that make sense now remember we
have this endpoint we're trying to get
suit right we're trying to find out what
a is we're trying to find out what B is
right in other words what I really want
is for these columns to be 1 right
for instance this is me a 1 not a 7 so
what do I do to this road to change that
you divide by 7 okay so I'm just
actually I can still fit this down here
right this whole first row divided by 3
that's going to be equivalent to this
line right 17 divided by 7 7 over 7 1 0
divided by 7 0 21 divided by 7 gives you
three so far good
ok
okay think think think think think I've
already worked out what a is right or UI
comma days so now how can I use this row
it's right near the first one to work
out what B is over here I want one to be
here how will I do it
I've got a white here right and I've got
a one here so if I take the first row
away from the second row I'll have
nothing here right to watch okay I've
got one zero okay so everything in the
first run I'm gonna take it away from
the second rope watch that's gonna
become zero negative two minus zero will
be negative two okay and then this will
be five minus three that's - that is
where's that that's this line you see
that - two Biggie's driven the other way
around - to be they are my B's is equal
to two so I've got my a in the first row
what do I do the second row to solve it
I divide by negative 2 0 1 negative 1
can you see it now so now I look at this
and I'm finished I think saying all
right from the first run a equals 3 and
from the second row B is negative ok now
what did I do in terms of the arithmetic
I did exactly the same thing was over
here it's a bit unfamiliar because we're
not used to this kind of notation but
mathematically is the same